كانت اوكرانيا ربما على بعد خطوه واحده من
تغيير مسار الحرب كليا لصالحها لكن تشعر
ان هناك من خذلها فكل الضغوط الدوليه
والدعوات والتعهدات الاوكرانيه لم تنجح في
اقناعي المانيا بالموافقه على ارسال
الدباباتها الحاسمه في هذا الوقت الحساس
من الحرب الرفض الالماني وضع كيف في
مواجهه ضعيفه نوعا ما امام روسيا وترك
واشنطن وحلفاء اوكرانيا امام خيارات
محدوده سيما وان اكياس بامثل حاجه في
الوقت الراهن لهذا الدعم بعد تدمير وتعطل
دباباتها منذ بدايه الحرب في الوقت الذي
تستعد فيه روسيا لهجوم واسع وشيك لكن
لماذا ترفض المانيا ارسال الدباباتها
لاوكرانيا في البدايه امجد البرلين خشيتها
لان مخزونه الجيش الالماني من هذه
الدبابات ليس كبيرا كما اشترت برلين ان
ترسل امريكا اولا دبابات لكيف مقابل ارسال
الدباباتها لاحقا
الدفاع الالماني وبرر التردد الالماني
بالقلق من تبعات ارسال الدبابات وما قد
ينجم عن تصاعدي وتره الحرب يعني يمكن ان
نقول ان المانيا تخشى رد فعل موسكو او
تحسب حساب اي انتقام روسيه خصوصا وان
روسيا تعلم جيدا ما قد تحدثه هذه الدبابات
من فرق على ارض المعركه فما الذي يميزها
فعليا نتابع خصائص الدبابه الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
والمانيا لم تقفل الباب نهائيا بشان مساله
ارسال الدبابات لاوكرانيا وقالت انها لم
تقرر بعد ولكنها رفضت تحديد قطر زمنيه
لقراره البيان الفرنسي الالماني بعد لقاء
الرئيس مانويل ماكرون والمستشرز اشترط فيه
الرئيس الفرنسي بان ارسال دبابات
الاوكرانيا يجب ان لا يعرض امن بلاده
للخطر بدوره قال
المتشرطس تعليقا على تزويد اكتاف بدبابات
تو ان الامر يتم بالتشور مع الحلفاء
وتعاهد بمواصله الدعم عموما
زومبا الطريقه التي سرقناها في الماضي
ومناقشه الاوضاع عن كثب ما اصدقائنا
وحلفائنا هي التي سنمضي بها في المستقبل
نخشى ان تستمر هذه الحرب لفتره طويله
ولهذا من المهم بنسبه الى اوكرانيا ان
تعلم اننا لن نتوادى في دعمنا وسنواصل
العمل طالما كان ذلك ضروريا وهو ما فعلناه
خلال الفتره الماضيه ولا يزال الامر مهما
للمستقبل نعمل من خلال التنسيق الوثيق
بيننا
فيما يتعلق بمدرعه لوكلاخ طلبت من وزير
الدفاع الاشتغال على الموضوع لا شيء
مستبعد والتقييم سيتم بشكل جماعي
وبالاستناد على ثلاثه معايير اولا وكما
فعل النموذج البدايه ان لا يتم الامر بغرض
التصعيد وقد التزمنا بهذه النقطه المعيار
الثاني هو ان نستطيع تقديم مساعده حقيقيه
وفعاله لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين وثا اخذوا
التطورات الميدانيه بعاني الاعتبار فضلا
عن مده التدريب التي يتطلبها استخدام
المدرب